At this point,
I want to do a review of what we've built thus far using the document outline.
You will notice that there are two scenes in our app currently,
one with the microphone button and the other one that is empty.
If I expand this first scene, you will notice that it has the microphone button,
the recording in progress label, and also the stop button.
All of these three elements are enclosed within this view here, and
this view is managed by this view controller over here.
So if I slide out Utilities, we can actually confirm that the class that
is managing or controlling this view is called ViewController.
The second scene is empty right now,
which means that it currently has nothing in its view.
And its current view controller, if I slide out the utility area,
I can see is the iOS class UIViewController.
So another way to visualize this is to say that in the first scene,
we have a view with several buttons.
We also know that this view is controlled by a class we
made called ViewController.
This class inherits from UIViewController, which is a class that Apple wrote.
The second scene currently has an empty view,
which is controlled by UIViewController directly.
So we can easily spot views and view controllers in this image.
You may notice, however, that the M of this acronym, or
model, is currently missing from our image.
This is because we haven't recorded any audio just yet in our app.